Let us examine the relationship
between the method of generate and
test, and human cognition.
Humans use generate and test as
the problem-solving method all the time.
This is because we do not have complete
or correct knowledge of the world.
We do not have infinite
computational resources.
And we also do not always have
recourse to a method of reasoning
that is guaranteed to be correct.
When you do not have these things,
then you use your own test method.
You come up with particular solutions to
a problem, you test the solutions out.
Beyond human cognition,
I'm sure you've come across
the notion of genetic algorithms.
Genetic algorithms are inspired by
the processes of biological evolution.
Through operations like crossover and
mutation,
one can generate solutions that can then
be tested against some fitness function.
Genetic algorithm are a good example
of the genetical test method.
First, genetic solutions,
then test them out.
So this method of generating test is
connected not only with human cognition,
but dependently,
also with biological evolution.
It's all over the place.